one of my friends William Costello
evolutionary psychologist out here in
Austin at UT
um he was explaining the fact that there
is a greater prejudice against people of
the same race with a different accent
Than People of A different race with the
same accent and the explanation for this
is pretty simple that evolutionarily
ancestrally it would have been very
unlikely for us to encounter somebody of
A different race but very likely for us
to encounter someone that had a slightly
different dialect or a slightly
different accent and what that means is
that you have very interesting
um Crossing prejudices and counteracting
prejudices for instance if you were to
see an Arab man that walked into the
room but then started speaking like
somebody that was from the south end of
London or whatever it might be if you
have someone who's race and accent do
not line up for instance I mean
everybody can think about this if you
were to see somebody walk into the room
that deserve a different race to you but
speaks with the same same accent yeah
you would immediately think well there's
we have an awful awful lot in common you
you have to forget you forget about the
fact that they're of A different race
but then you flip that round okay let's
have somebody walk into the room who is
of the same race as you yeah but has an
entirely different sort of accent there
is immediately a big distance and I I
just thought that that totally blew my
mind okay you're telling me that there
is more prejudice against people with
different accents than people of
different races like just totally it
makes perfect sense uh the way you've
explained it and William Costello
um absolutely nailed it right on the
head there the thing I would add to that
um is I was talking to uh probably
shouldn't mention who it is I was
talking to um one of the UK's top
Impressionists
um the other day uh and interestingly uh
we were talking about impressionism
um as um as an art form and as a form of
humor
um and he said that he'd come across
people actually who had pointed the
finger at Impressionists as cultural
appropriators which is a very
interesting argument
um now whereas I don't buy it uh whereas
you know I think we have an innate
Fascination for different voices coming
out of um the same person he's very
incongruous it the incongruity principle
is very powerful in in all kinds of
things that's why we're so fascinated
with serial killers for example because
they appear on the outside to be very
normal but of course they've got these
you know horrendous alter egos raging
behind the scenes
um if you have different voices coming
out of the same person
uh then there is a real fascination with
that so we're fascinated by him
personally there's an impressionist but
actually recently there's been recent
Lobby saying well actually you know if
you're doing different accents or taking
people off then why is that not cultural
appropriation let's not go down that
road mate because that's another two
hours we can sit there talking about
that one but it's a good one to throw
out there but interestingly it's it's
it's it's very uh
when you look at when you talk to
someone
and again this is something that this
guy this impersonated this impressionist
uh who I was talking to uh delved into
and I'm sure you do it uh I certainly do
it if you really like someone
sometimes without knowing it you end up
talking a little bit like them when
you're in conversation with someone you
might adopt a little bit of their speech
patterns might not be their accent
sometimes it is in extreme cases but you
might unconsciously mirror uh the tone
or the speed uh at which or the tempo
which they're speaking so the voice of
somebody is something that we find it
very difficult not to empathize with so
that's where William Costello was coming
from there that's one that's another
reason an empathy reason when we look
when we hear voices
um it's it's one of those things that is
a marker of how we gain an impression of
someone
um and we're very very susceptible to to
to to sound coming out of people's uh of
lips and how they sound
let me throw some bro signs at you is it
the case that accents get locked in and
are less likely to change as you grow up
but are more likely to change if you are
younger let's say that you spend the
first seven years of your life in
Ireland and then you move to America or
whatever you're going to end up with
pretty much just an American accent and
if you maybe make the move at sort of 13
or 14 you're going to end up with sort
of an Irish American accent after maybe
10 years yeah
would that be adaptive in case
ancestrally you ended up merging with
another tribe perhaps being taken over
by another tribe and it would be in your
interests to align yourself in terms of
your accent with the accent of the new
tribe that you have joined because that
is going to be one of the key
determinants in not making you an
outsider yeah I mean you know what Chris
you should I don't know if you've ever
studied psychology maybe you should
definitely give it a go I mean I'd never
heard that before
um never thought of that before I think
it's an absolutely cool Theory
um and I can see that there's I could
instantly pull out and they have a lot
of evidence to to back that up
um absolutely the ability and you know
I'm going to do a study actually because
no one's really looked at it what makes
people why are some of us really good at
changing our accents and why are some of
us not so good what makes great
impression is great Impressionists
there's all kinds of different things
there's the the flexibility of the vocal
tract for example so there's all going
to be all kinds of individual
differences in this but yeah the ability
to change your accent and to blend in uh
would indeed uh confer
um an evolutionary Advantage uh going
forward absolutely what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]